what has philanthropy actually solved
and it's not a lot like think about them
we've put hundreds of millions of
dollars into
cancer research and solving hunger and
disaster relief or climate change and we
don't have real solutions
private flame three works in a couple
areas uh vaccines
coronavirus is actually a good example
but malaria smallpox like crazy
innovative research where private
philanthropists can take crazy risk
prove concept and then let the
governments or big in non-profit
organizations who are allowed
to take risk see that see it as a safer
bet
and then pour resources into it um
but hunger homelessness cancer like
those are not places where private
philanthropy has really done well
why can't private philanthropy solve
hunger like one of the posts i saw
was saying how you know i'm gonna tell
my kids this is why one in three
children are hungry right now
because you have bezos instead of paying
income taxes is
you know flying his penis rocket to
space like why is that wrong
[Music]
welcome back to yank speaks everybody
this is your weekly thursday update
where
it's yang speaks yang and friends speak
you've got zach realm
just friends speak just friend speak
well yang doesn't speak today
yang's friends speak yang's friend speak
on your thursday update you're all used
to it by now carly riley
the one and only you're all used to it
but that won't stop six of you from
being like where's the yang
that's fair and hopefully those are
that's because we're growing and people
are finding out about the pod
um and where this is our week on
thursdays
um well monday's andrew does an
interview and and gives his take on the
world and
on thursdays we look carly and i look to
break down a topic that's being
misunderstood in the media
last week we did socialism well i wanted
to say first of all thank you we got a
ton of engagement on the episode
some people loved it some people thought
we weren't generous enough to socialism
i've read your comments i've checked out
the like socialist thinkers you
recommended to me
i have to say i stand by our episode but
i have learned more since then so i
really appreciate it in particular
dr richard wolff is somebody you all
said to watch so if anybody out there is
interested in learning more you can
check out
richard wolff he makes a really
interesting
argument about uh state capitalism and
says that cuba's actually a state
capitalist society
so again it's everybody trying to
redefine what socialism is but
i thought it was interesting so much
appreciated all of you who gave records
charlie p riley on instagram she will
post a response of some sort on this bad
boy
oh will i okay apparently i'm now locked
into posting you've been like playing
around with all week just do it girl
okay
harley p riley twitter and instagram and
thank you for i got some good dm's too
so appreciate the dms always i'm
sometimes slow to respond but i
try to get around to it so this week
this is something i'm very very
passionate about i don't know if carly's
as passionate about it but don't care i
mean i care i care about you um
but i think the world has missed this
one um we're talking about
billionaires in space um
and so for those of you i'm assuming
most you've heard this because this was
national news pretty much everywhere
jeff bezos the ceo of amazon as well as
richard branson the guy who started
virgin records and his version
everything now um they both spent
billions of dollars to go
to space and the media does not know
what to do with this
so i'm very excited because there's kind
of two narratives
and i'm curious scarlett make sure i get
this right because most of my life is
just asking you if i'm doing it right
um is on
one side the press freaks out like oh my
gosh such a great story like
billionaires in space this is awesome
we love covering super rich people um
and we love covering people go to space
um but on the other hand particularly
from the left
there's a narrative that this is a
complete waste of money
and capitalism gone wrong and they
should be using the money to save the
world um
now so did i get that right carly that's
not there i think so
yes yeah so
only very clear this is not and will not
ever be a defend the billionaires
podcast
um there are plenty of reasons not to
like billionaires and jeff bezos
um whether it's not paying workers
enough or
uh i will say i kind of hate that like
we're gonna hate billionaires
like narrative i think that's stupid
like billionaires are all different
individuals
pre you know forget j.k rowling's recent
scandal like
she's somebody who became a billionaire
just by writing amazing books like you
know like people have become
billionaires by doing
very wholesome things and very terrible
things right um
but i want to um and we want to make
sure
i think it's helpful to understand this
narrative and particularly for myself
personally i've worked
in philanthropy before um at the highest
levels
with these types of people and i know
what's not being covered at least from
that side of things so
i want to dive in and then at the end uh
the back half of this we're going to
we're going to make a crypto call which
i think you all should be excited
it's not a crypto call this is classic
exactly it's not a crypto nfc
it's an nft it's an unfunctional token
which that's not a type of crypto
how many crypto podcast
interviews i have to do
and listen to to get the damn
terminology right
ah i mean it's in the crypto world i
give up
it's still cool though and y'all are
gonna like it alright
billionaires in space
um i guess i'll dive in and we'll get
your take carl
um so
i i like starting with some some facts
and carla hop in so basically jeff bezos
is worth 209 billion dollars which is
ridiculous um uh his company
blue origin is looking um basically to
find a profitable model to explore space
whether it's space tourism or other
types of recyclable rockets things like
that
he's been auctioning off space trips and
some have been going for upwards of
hundreds a hundred million dollars
ridiculous he's had 15 successful
flights and he just went up um about a
week and a half ago
um and his back
he spent like five and a half billion
dollars for like a ten minutes
ten minutes in space or attended flight
whatever it was
his quote was we're going to build a
road to space so our kids and their kids
can build the future
um and he did have some kind of douchey
moments
where he was like he thanked all the
amazon employees and i was like dude
he thanked all of us who are amazing i
guess he's better than not thanking them
but
i don't know the question for me is like
did he
was he doing that intentionally to rile
the internet or did he not realize that
he was
like is he actually that out of touch so
if anybody missed this
jeff bezos said i want to thank the
amazon employees and like amazon
customers
because you guys paid for this and
like you know the left had a field day
with that
understandably and uh i i don't know if
he
if he just doesn't realize or if he was
like intentionally who knows
jeff bezos is being jeff ben and for
context so richard branson has his
company virgin galactic
uh he's one of trying to do space
tourism which is
i think he has 600 people signed up for
reservations that cost
a quarter of a million dollars each uh
and then elon musk
is wasn't in the news per se this for
this but he has spacex and he's kind of
included in this billionaire's going to
space for the record there are other
billionaires working on this as well
but these are your big name players um
and it's a cool story
because you got billionaires they're
doing awesome stuff they're competing
it's the billionaire space race
um and then this whole narrative from
the left isn't evil
and that's what um we wanted to talk
about today
um i am i'm excited about this your
perspective on this is interesting
i don't know if people fully understand
your background and maybe we dive into
it a little bit more in just a second
because i think it's worth
understanding what you did do in your
past life um as both a founder of a
non-profit that's going to be what worth
a million dollars this year and
as somebody who worked with the biggest
charitable givers in the in the world
but
i think first like you kind of outlined
this the media narratives we're seeing
are are not just about like what's in
the media right i think we have some
headlines here of like
what all that money that's being spent
on space exploration could help to solve
right that seemed to be a big narrative
oh jeff bezos spent 5.5 billion dollars
to be in space for four minutes
you know here are the seven things that
that money would have been better spent
on
how the billionaire space race could be
one giant leap for pollution
you're getting a lot of that i missed
nbc was my favorite
was uh jeff bezos live blue origin space
launch is the pinnacle of waste
uh fun fun fun well and you but you also
have
what i thought was interesting because i
wasn't tracking a lot of those media
headlines was the social media
like outrage over this the memes were
everywhere i think right like you have
you know there was one of that with the
quote men will literally launch
themselves into space instead of going
to therapy
you know and then you had like jamila
jamil who i tend to really like jesus
just got divorced yes
yeah yeah jamila jamil was like oh wait
wait like so which billionaire got to be
in space first like oh wait i don't care
these guys you know sure flying to
space is cool but have you ever tried
paying income tax like
that was that was generally kind of you
know big social media names that was the
sentiment
um and then the other one that i thought
was interesting was the comparisons that
i saw all over the place
of how much time the media dedicated to
talking about
bezos in space as opposed to how much
time they've spent talking about other
things
so for example uh on the sunday or
whenever it was that bezos went into
space like
america whatever cbs this morning like
all these news shows
collectively spent more time talking
about bezos in space than they had spent
talking about climate change
in all of 2020. um so that's getting
people mad like ah you know they're
making climate change worse meanwhile
the media won't even cover climate
change
um so i think that's sort of the the
background so
there was one article probably my
favorite global citizen
listed off things he could have used the
money for instead so if you had 5.5
billion dollars what else could you
spend it on and
they said and i don't call me this is
global citizen whether their numbers are
accurate or not they've seen ballpark
enough but they said he could have saved
three
uh 37.5 million people from starving he
could have vaccinated the world which i
think is bs because vaccinations are
actually not a cost problem their
distribution problem but that would be
2.6 billion
to vaccinate the world just from a cost
perspective on
medicine um and then humanitarian
interventions
are believed to um if you spent a
billion in nigeria or
two billion in the congo or a billion
and a half or so in afghanistan you'll
be able to solve a lot of those crises
again a bit of a stretch but this is
what
people are saying he should have spent
the money on other things so i wanted to
i think this is important um
to help us understand
is this wrong is this right what what
what what should average humans actually
think about this should we be pissed the
billionaires are spending much money
space maybe a lot of us don't care but
it's forced in our faces anyway so i
think having an opinion on it should be
helpful in informed opinion
um so
uh maybe i'll maybe i'll start carl i
guess
um unless you want to take this
different direction i'm thinking um
here's what's where we're at i used to
basically help
very very like 100 million dollar plus
um
philanthropists and rich people give
money to charity and i used to help
other people do that as well on our team
um when i was on wall street and so
here's a general
perspective well you ran what you ran
what's up what did you what was
you ran like client philanthropy
services at ubs i was head of client
philanthropy solutions at
ubs which was a fancy title will go
around and help people with their giving
um
but um
a number of thoughts let's dive in here
quick
just to set the record strength jeff
bezos is philanthropy he's been
hammered in the press for not doing a
lot of things maybe your traditional
billionaires are doing public or
traditional public billionaires
but he is objectively the top two
philanthropists in the entire world
last year were himself and his wife who
took half of his net worth
in a divorce um he created a 10 billion
basis earth fund to fight climate change
he's donated 100 million
to feed america in 2018 he gave a
billion dollars to fund education
homelessness he's given millions
before that so he is whether we want to
call him greedy or not he's the biggest
philanthropist in the world at least
right now now he's not bill gates i mean
it's different
how they tallied this up is when you
give it you know so if you start a
family foundation with
10 billion dollars you're not giving
that all at once
um so the gates foundation has given
more on a yearly basis but in terms of
pure philanthropy
has he pledged to give all his money
away is he one of those billionaires
so there's something called the giving
pledge that um
i believe bill gates started um which is
the wealthiest people in the world
billionaires pledged
buffett uh started it without he signed
it
no but i'm pretty sure buff it because
buffett gave all pledged to give all his
money to the gates foundation
and that's what kicked it off i'm a big
buffett head so
jimmy that's not less important but the
point is that billionaires all the world
are signed this pledge to give away half
of their wealth is what it is they give
away half
um jeff bezos is one of the few who has
not signed it
yeah and that's why i think it's bill
and warren together that's
what you're like he's not a particularly
generous dude bezos like
it you're like oh he gave a ton of money
but like it reminds me of what's that
the bible story of like the woman who
gave one cent but it was like all she
had
versus the man who gave 100 million
dollars that's not what the number was
in the bible
and he had 10 billion like i i don't
think what he's doing i don't think he's
a generous dude at all and i think i
will
i would argue debatable because there's
plenty of billionaires that we do not
know about that don't give anything
so they're really ungenerous but that
shouldn't agree but here's the other
piece
is warren buffett like had not done
anything major philanthropically until
he decided to give it all away at the
end of his life
so there's talking about about 60 years
plus where he was not a philanthropist
no but okay and buffett has spoken about
this right and he a regrets it but b
buffett doesn't care about money but
he's a competitive dude and so he was
like i wasn't giving my money away
because
watching myself get richer was how i
measured that i was succeeding at the
thing that i loved
why can't bezos have the same
justification because he hasn't verbally
said
any of that why does he have to verbally
say that
why wouldn't he just make the giving
pledge if he was planning on giving it
away you're now in
you're making giving pledge at any point
in his life you're assuming that he's
going to i'm just going off of the
information i have and you're seeming to
like
project that maybe someday he'll make
this pledge and therefore we should
think he's generous
i'm not saying that he could give he
could not sign the pledge and give half
his mouth away
like pledge is this symbolic thing that
he may be okay but he's not giving half
his wealth away i'm based on what we
know thus far and what we know thus far
is he's given away a paltry sum compared
to what he has and he's given no
indication that he's going to give away
more
whereas buffett yes didn't give away for
a while but has explained why and has
said he's giving all of his money away
not even just half of it he's probably
half the age of buffett
one two saying that there's no
indication that he's given
uh that he's made no indication he's
gonna give more away he gave 10 billion
dollars away last year he's a large out
of
205 9 billion sure but a lot of that's
it liquid so it's not like i mean
i understand that he could give more i'm
not trying to defend this guy but to say
that he's not a philanthropist
is ridiculous um and to say that he's
not
relatively generous is ridiculous oh i
think that i think that's what's not
ridiculous at all i think to say he's
not relatively generous is exactly what
you can say
how many people give five percent of
their net worth away every year
not that many i mean i believe is that
what he gave five percent
well yeah ten is tithing like that's to
me giving five
first of all i don't know i guess he's
given two and a half he's 200 billion
right but i'm assuming there's some
like illiquid stuff he can't get rid of
like if his liquid assets what he can
give i guess he can give it liquid
assets dudes if he had a good advisor
but
anyway we digress here my point is um
he is giving a lot of money away um now
branson and musk have signed the giving
pledge they are pledged to give but also
they're giving buses embark they don't
give anything until they die so that
doesn't actually solve things we're
talking about here in terms of problems
[Music]
today
the question is should they be giving
their money this is what i think is fun
should they be giving their money to
charities to solve problems or should
they be exploring
space i don't think we should treat
these
given their wealth like they're mutually
exclusive um
and i think that's partly what's
happening here i'm gonna i'm gonna
answer your question with another
question um that i think we should think
about as we have this conversation
which is for the people who are really
mad about this
like what are they mad about like is it
is it are they mad that we're spending
money on going to space at all
like if the government was spending this
money would they
also be mad um or are they just mad
because they're billionaires and they're
mad that billionaires exist
and this is just symbolic of a system
that they hate
and i think it's probably that that
second one um which i'm more sympathetic
to
um the first question like i absolutely
think it's great that we spend money
uh even exorbitant amounts of money well
spent trying to
get to space and expand our
understanding of space
but let's we can use those questions as
some frames as you give us your
take because you actually do know quite
a lot about this so i i'm interested to
get into your take on this
and i think this story kind of touched
on everything like capitalism's problems
right now
plus our broken social are broken our
actual problems in society
whether they're part of capitalism or
not like broken gov and then like
government's inability to solve anything
like private citizens handling what the
government used to do um
plus it's billionaires we love talking
about billionaires in the media united
states um
okay so here's i wanna i want to be
clear i'm not defending
um i am going to defend jeff bezos and
the billionaires for this but
because i love these guys i just want to
give everybody some context as to why um
so um i agree with you this stuff isn't
mutually exclusive you can
spend a bunch of money go to space and
spend on charity but here's the one
thing a lot of people like kind of just
forget
giving that much money away is very very
hard
it is incredibly hard writing a million
dollar check to a charity
that doesn't have it like a like or
let's call it ten million dollars a
hundred million dollars
like that don't have the infrastructure
to take that much cash
is almost it's it's an impossible task
in many ways my own charity is going to
be a million-dollar organization suit up
what was really excited about but if you
gave us a 10 million dollar check like
we are run in a certain way that we
could scale but 100 million we like
we're not there yet um we have eight you
know eight staff whatever it is like
that's
like you're just scaling up um so what
are the what are like what are some of
the charities that can take
huge sums of money to like and that's
the biggest problem is that
the big the ones that can take that are
your universities
and your hospitals and the main issues
in
private philanthropy today like what are
the problems with why philanthropy
doesn't work
number one is a lot of these charities
do not and cannot take massive risk
so you end up getting money funneled to
a lot of safe bets which is names on
buildings or
treating symptoms instead of the cure um
there's a lot of talk in philanthropy on
your overhead and there's a guy named
dan pallotta has a ted talk on
uncharitable and one of the things he
talks about like we talk about overhead
which is like
people donors will say i want my money
to go to the cause and not
some executive director's yacht um
which is okay fine but the reality is
what does overhead
include that's not program money that
can include
technology research talent innovation
like recruiting people reinvestment back
in your business you're telling me that
apple or amazon don't spend
more than 10 of their profits or their
budget on overhead is ridiculous so
you're never hamstring a business that
way but we do that to our charities
um so you'd rather have a bigger pie
that spends 25
on research in tech and quote unquote
overhead than a smaller pie that's got
the perfect 90 10 that a lot of clients
want that's a big one
um and then a lot of them are um
a lot of people want to start their own
thing so a lot of private
philanthropists are there's like a
there's like the world has too many
charities i think the number we used to
tell our clients that 95
of for-profit startups fail in their
first two years
because that's capitalism that's how it
works but in charities
in non-profit land only 10 fail it's
less than that um so they just don't
fail this exists on in perpetuity and
suck resources from each other so this
is all an argument as to
what that it's so my point is for people
to be
and let's call it global citizen or the
left saying hey
jeff bezos should have sent that 5.5
billion dollars and use it to cure
hunger that's a very very
that's not an excuse to not do it but
that's not like it's not like he could
just donate like oh i solved hunger like
to actually solve a problem there um
it would take a massive amount of
innovation that i don't believe
philanthropy actually can solve and
that's the real question if you actually
ask yourself what has philanthropy
actually
solved and it's not a lot like think
about them we've put hundreds of
millions of dollars into
cancer research and solving hunger and
disaster relief or climate change and we
don't have real solutions
private philanthropy works in a couple
areas uh vaccines
coronavirus actually a good example but
malaria smallpox like crazy innovative
research where private philanthropists
can
take crazy risk prove concept and then
let the governments
or big in non-profit organizations who
are allowed to take risk
see that see it as a safer bet and then
pour resources into it
um but hunger homelessness cancer like
those are not places where private
philanthropy has really done well
so and at the risk of
making this redundant why can't private
philanthropy
solve hunger like one of the posts i saw
was saying how you know i'm gonna tell
my kids this is why one in three
children are hungry right now
because you have bezos instead of paying
income taxes
is you know flying his penis rocket to
space like why is that wrong
there's one that's treating the symptom
and they're treating the cure like the
cause of hunger right
um so you can feed people and we do that
right um there's a lot of philanthropy
that's spent
like giving food to the hungry and that
is important that's like a
i call that like disaster relief there
are people in need we have to help them
and that's what philanthropy should be
doing it's also what our government
should be doing
in order to actually solve hunger we
probably should get an answer on this
but the biggest
challenge is not at least in what i've
researched it's not
a food quantity issue it's a
distribution issue it's a government
issue
it's a um i mean every government's
different
um so could but could a private
individual with enough money
solve that distribution issue i mean if
they were able to bribe every single
government official to get them to do
what they want
like i don't like you know and maybe
jeff bezos could create uh
on why don't you tell the world bank
story
when i was on wall street i i asked a
very senior
woman from the world bank and she well
she asked all of us if you had a
infinity money what would you use it to
what causes would you
um focus on to cure and solve and
everybody went around they said the
usual education that's that anything
and then i flipped it back on her i was
like what would you do and she said i
would
use the money to bribe the men and
mainly men but the people in power
around the world
um to solve the most pressing problems
in the world um
because and that's probably
the only way you'd solve hunger because
you like jeff bezos is not
the government of india um where he can
like india has a caste system right they
believe that they're very poor
have like done something to deserve that
um
your fighting against there are problems
that are so big and this is a bill gates
thing that i've heard him say so this
makes some sense to me as i'm
learning about this like there are some
problems that are so huge
you actually need something at the scale
of government to solve them correct
and and yet gates talks about that like
there are things that you just can't
solve
privately uh yes so there's risks that
governments and businesses
um and that that's the challenge you
need the government to solve them and
sometimes a private sector but there are
certain risks that those areas
can't take like some ideas are too crazy
um
for a government if you're an elected
official you can't be betting on crazy
new technologies that are very expensive
because
people will find out if they don't work
you lose right you don't win your next
election
um the a lot
some of these really good ideas like
let's call it solving hunger and like a
local level
takes what they call patient capital
where it's like i have to build the
infrastructure
and the the community
and the the businesses need to grow and
the hospital needs to get better it's
like this slower and you don't make your
money back the way you would in a
business or you don't have the results
the way you'd want like a government
so that's where private philanthropy
should come in where they come in like
i'll put up the crazy risk i can i can
fail as a private philanthropist
because you can't but if it works then i
want you to scale it
um jaclyn novogratz we've had mike it's
the sister i believe of mike novogratz
who's been on this podcast
started an organization called acumen
and our whole thing is about patient
capital
like building a hospital that's not
going to have a roi in the first five
10 20 years but over time that
government can pick up the tab because
it's starting because the community's
building and the profit models start to
work and as a business or government can
start to come in
um so
a long way of saying um be like basil
should be solving world hunger and
helping us
he is donating i believe like giving tim
he's the number one philanthropist in
the world and so is his
ex-wife i don't see a future where he's
not like
pressured to give even more in that
world um
but also what are you gonna what is he
gonna do like he's literally looking
like how do i give away
50 billion if i wanted to give away 100
billion dollars how the hell do i do
that
and what am i solving you better do
something awesome like that's a really
hard challenge i'm not be like boo hoo
jeff bezos
but seriously it is very difficult and
if you listen to bill and melinda gates
talk about their foundation
they talk about how impossible
it is to give
money away an effective way that you
would the way you would invest it
because these social problems are
complicated they are not black and white
they are not measured effectively it's
tough to measure and find results
[Music]
so there's a concept in philanthropy i
think it's philanthropy or in the world
right that's like
measure anything you're going to do with
your money against just giving it to
people
obviously that's a big thing you and i
are advocates for why shouldn't he just
you know figure out a way to do a
massive ubi or hell just like use his
personal wealth to pay amazon employees
more
and just use that money to just give it
to other people
that's not a bad one um we're talking
about two and a half percent of it so
here's the other thing
um and i wrote this down so i um
i don't think he's mutually this isn't
what we're talking about is not mutually
exclusive like him giving away
two and a half percent of his wealth for
the space race does not mean he can't
give hundreds of billions of dollars to
do a ubi or something crazy
um my concern and if i was his advisor
like find something that's sustainable
and not
you know curing the symptom for a short
period of time but that's a different
challenge
so the big one for me and like why space
is actually
in my opinion relatively philanthropic
and has hot philanthropic and has
high roi there's a couple things one our
government's not doing it so if we
are passionate as a human race about
space exploration
billionaires have to step up that's
number one um
and philanthropies aren't doing it and
governments are seeing is too risky like
it's too expensive and too risky
whatever it is
the second thing is it is massive upside
here both for-profit
and philanthropically and i think that
either
we popularized space travel
over time to the point where you could
take a rocket from here to london
and get there and you know from new york
to london and get there in
two hours or so and that would change a
whole bunch of ways we do business
or you start to colonize space yeah but
isn't there a good argument to be made
that says like oh yay now like you know
the already rich people essentially who
do
global business can get to london a
little bit faster
but isn't it better if we again give
poor people money
instead of being able to do that that
like that advancement is not actually
great it's not it's not it's a fair
point but it's like
i don't know like how valuable is it
that we can have planes going like
people can travel across the country so
i will say
okay so and that's not just a rich
people thing but poor people children
like
the average american is flying on a
plane once a year i imagine um
no no no i don't think so absolutely not
poor americans certainly are not once a
year
poor americans we should look look that
up but it is not just business people
traveling there are plenty of people
you were saying you were going to london
do you know how
average americans are not going on
vacation london's a bad example but you
could take a rocket anywhere when people
go and maybe maybe cheaper for people go
to australia or go see a relative who's
across the world
one of the coolest comparisons i heard
was to
maritime travel in the 1400s which is
you know in 1450 if you were going to
take a ship
from spain for example to
some other part of the world which at
that point we didn't even know really
what existed because we hadn't fully
traversed the globe
it was incredibly risky it would have
seemed like a terrible use of money
because
the odds that you sunk or just
disappeared and never came back
etc were very very high and yet
what that exploration got us was like
insurance for the first time
like you know all sorts of things that
in modern day we actually value that are
good for any number of people and of
course like
we now live in a global world in ways
that are largely very beneficial
i mean there's obviously you can come at
me for like colonialism etc
um and so one of the things that we know
is being worked on as part of the space
race is global broadband
and being able to provide internet now
from satellites
to the entire world including people in
like third world countries who right now
don't have any access or you know very
little access to the internet and what
that has the potential to do
in terms of making a truly global
marketplace in terms of people suddenly
earning money
that did shift my perspective a little
bit of what's being underestimated
on the part of people who are really
opposed to this
is how much innovation can come out of
really important valuable innovation can
come out of
investing in in space and what the point
you're making which i think is
interesting
is that it should be private
philanthropists doing this
because the government should not be
taking on this kind of risk blowing this
kind of money
but that we should be doing it and so
the people who should be doing it
are exactly this and if the government
and if if elon
and branson and jeff bezos create
recyclable rockets that cut the cost
down and go into space by 25 or 50 or 75
percent
and next you know we can travel to
saturn works with men on mars
eventually if we have to back up the
hard drive because of an extinction
level event on earth and we have to
colonize mars or the moon or
god forbid any stuff we'll be thanking
them and for
two and a half percent of his net worth
or whatever the heck like for this for a
drop in the bucket for jeff
this has high upside that no one else is
really willing or able to take so that
is my defense to this
the big one to me for those of you that
are like well billionaires shouldn't
exist this way that's the thing to me
don't hate the player hate the game like
what jeff bezos is doing theoretically
has massive upside for humanity
i don't think we should matter to him um
objectively i'm not a human being you
can be mad
okay here's a question for you though so
anon giroud
how do i pronounce his last name eurydos
who wrote um
winner take all or whatever which was a
book that yang loves i know you love
about
about basically how you get these people
sorry
yeah you get super rich and then they
give their money away a little bit and
pat themselves on the back and feel like
they've made a difference when really
they haven't so he wrote a book that
makes that argument
he has said about this and i'll shout
out griffshark i think was his name
somebody
username on our youtube comments last
time brought this to my attention which
i appreciate
um which was anan's argument that
basically
like america and what's great about
america was built on this balance
between what we do as a collective what
we do together
and then what we do alone and that this
whole billionaire space
race is an example of this balance being
totally out of whack
um i'm curious on your thoughts on that
one thing that comes to mind for me is
in this maritime analogy i was making
uh a lot of those spa you know those
ship explorations that happened in the
1400s were a combination of private
investors and government investment
um which you know helps ensure that
there's a sort of collective benefit to
be had from it
i don't know what's your any thoughts on
that take so
i guess from my experience in talking to
the big philanthropists the issue is not
what's getting done in some ways i think
there's times where government will have
to make an investment no one wants to
make and you like that but
other times philanthropists can do it
too so it's less about that the big one
to me
the biggest challenge of where
philanthropy is going is oversight
and bazel is not the best example
because that is
um or at least like musk like spacex a
public company um
like blue i don't think blue origin is
public but it's like there'll be
some level of of oversight there i guess
and plus it's very public
but um like they're making a big deal
about it but
so there are a lot of philanthropists
who wanted more flexibility than
starting a private foundation or
starting a non-profit so private
foundation you have to give away you
basically give all the money at one
point you get your tax deduction there
and then you have to give away
i believe it's like five percent a year
or so there's like required distribution
maybe ten percent depends on
but um uh it's been a while since i've
been doing it but at least five percent
um you have to give away a certain
amount a year but you don't the rest can
just be invested
um but that has rules and regulations
and
the irs and um are actually closely
monitoring private foundations those get
audited a lot
um what mark zuckerberg
for example did with his wife they
started they didn't even do it for the
tax purposes they started an llc
the chan zuckerberg initiative i think
it's called um their philanthropic
efforts are all done in a for-profit
vehicle just do what they want
which in one hand is really cool because
they can take crazy risk and do what
they want they don't have to get five
percent of you they don't have to worry
about
uh doing things that are purely
altruistic whatever it is but
there's no public accountability because
a non-profit is technically owned by the
public so there's no
awareness of who's on the board um
there's no
direct oversight what every dollar spent
on so things like that so that
um to me is the biggest challenge we're
supposed to do this stuff together
um or some of these things affect all of
us but there's no government oversight
on how it happens that's the biggest
challenge
okay well i think this is interesting i
want to wrap us to our our final topic
here bring us to our final topic here um
don't eat the play hate the game
carly appreciate your take on this
you know maybe people hate me that's
like just that's just so we need another
no i actually think you might bring up
defending billionaires no no you bring a
certain amount of knowledge to this that
i think most people don't actually have
they don't understand how it works and
that's again that's been a criticism
i've heard of of the people who are
criticizing the billionaires is that a
lot of these folks are like commentators
and haven't actually tried to like
solve these problems in a big way and
don't realize how hard it actually
is and that this this this space work is
actually really valuable
and then critics man it's critics but
there's valid point i mean like richard
branson tried to get a bunch of money
from
the uk government to bail out virgin
atlantic in ways that like
or virgin galactic or whatever that or i
think it's virgin atlantic whatever it
just like
that riles me up because i'm like let
capitalism do its thing let these
companies fail also you have 5.2 billion
dollars feel free to bail it out
yourself
if you're like you know so upset like
now you want government money like that
that does really get me oh the fact they
don't pay income taxes i got plenty of
bonuses
yeah and that's now this is that's the
system not necessarily the billionaire
specifically but
it's um it's messed up
okay speaking of money predict the
future
last topic well no i was going to say
that our final topic i think was going
to be stoner cats which is just
something we wanted to bring to people's
attention
okay so stoner cats
like gift goats which i talked about a
while back these nfts always have silly
upgraded that somehow involve animals um
stoner cats is an nft project being
launched really by mila
kunis i guess but also with ash and
kutcher
fascinatingly vitalik buterin is
involved in this vitalik is the the
founder of
ethereum so that was cool that they got
him and uh
it is an nft project that was supposed
to drop chris rock
well okay we'll get there so this is
good they're not actually really behind
the product though they're just actors
they're still involved
okay so let me give it to you so zach
this nft project was supposed to drop
yesterday as we're recording this it's
it's tuesday july 27th
when we record this um it was supposed
to drop yesterday monday at 2 00 p.m
pacific time
they had to push the launch back to
today um i'm gonna give a quick pro
launch already by the way by the time
this airs unless they push it back
unless they push it back okay i'm gonna
give you the quick pros and cons and
the rundown the pros of this project is
it's really cool and innovative
basically if you buy one of these nfts
and they're going for like
.35 eth which is like 800 bucks or
whatever
current prices it eats um if you buy one
of these
you it unlocks 45 minutes
of content created by some like
bigwigs in hollywood so you have like
the people who animated spider-man
who have you know a bunch of different
like animators people who created some
cool tv shows
and then this content is voiced by the
actors
are mila kunis ashton kutcher seth
macfarlane
jane fonda um who's the one i miss you
chris rock
and then vitalik buterin vitalik buterin
who's the founder of ethereum
and so it's like an all-star cast it
seems to be an all-star team creating
this animated series called stoner cats
and then there are all sorts of other
perks like about cats like what could go
wrong
is cats getting high and there's all
sorts of other benefits
if you become a token holder of this nft
like you get
you know additional perks and say in the
content and and the idea here is that
this will hopefully fund
other projects so it's the first example
that at least that i know of
of nfts basically funding like a
production company and putting the power
in the hands of the viewers as opposed
to in the hands of a traditional studio
those are the pros i think conceptually
super cool i'm investing in it because i
love that concept i want to see more of
this
and hey like call out to the socialism
thing this is what you're talking about
like this is
the worker collective it's like the
money's all social things then i don't
want to invest anymore
but oh my goodness calm down okay so and
then
the cons what are the cons
this team has not done a fantastic job
of building their community around this
project and
right now in nft world it is very
important to build a strong community
for your nft before it launches um and i
think
there's been two failings on this on
this front you have
all of these celebrity mainstream
players who are involved in this project
and they are doing very little to
promote it or to educate their audiences
on how to set up a metamask wallet for
example and therefore to buy an
nft using eth like they have not done
the requisite education piece to draw in
the mainstream audience and they're also
not letting you buy this with a credit
card it's like nba top shot
is a is an nft project that's done very
well with the mainstream
because you can use a credit card for it
um so they have not
they don't have the infrastructure for
the mainstream and then and then they
have not
you know educated the mainstream on how
to buy eth which is a missed opportunity
on a whole bunch of friends seth
macfarlane isn't even tweeting about
this nor is chris rock et cetera
so that means the people they're
attracting are the
like crypto nft insiders who don't
really give an f that these people are
celebrities and just want like a cool
a cool project um and on this front
they've sort of delivered because the
project seems cool but they haven't
really like paid their respects to the
inner community to make them feel
comfortable and like they really know
what they're doing
so they had to delay the launch
yesterday because they messed up some of
the tech
and instead of doing what some of these
other projects have done when they have
to delay their launch because that's
actually pretty common
and say hey okay sorry we're gonna have
to delay
you know we'll give you 24 hours notice
before this thing drops it sort of kept
everybody on edge they didn't give us a
sense of like when the new eta was
so people were getting really mad
they're like this is disrespectful to
the community you're making us sit here
and
wait and waste our day um instead of
handling it the way you're supposed to
so
the cons seem to be they don't yet seem
to be really good at navigating like
the whole nft crypto community the pros
are that i think it's innovative and
super cool
and for that reason i'm gonna put some
heath towards it um but everyone should
check it out stoner cats stoner cats tv
see what you think we're investing if we
lose our shirt
and this is like i can't it's not
investing enough to lose our shirt don't
invest so much that you're going to lose
i can't tell if we're just bitter that
we missed on the gift goat
and like stoner cat is our like
consolation prize or
i'm kind of betting on the show being
good because that i think will bring out
yes throughout our community but
the fact that these celebs have not
tweeted about it makes me worry that
it's not very good
i don't think that's it i think they
just don't want to have to educate they
don't want to start answering questions
about like how do i get access to this
show
i mean look clearly spending 800 for 45
minutes of content is an absurd value
proposition
of course well you get other episodes
right or is it one you one token per
episode
no no each episode is like five or six
minutes the episodes are really short
they have a total of 45 minutes of
content for this first drop
but then the idea is that they're going
to expand into more content and as a
token holder
you have like say in what gets developed
and you get you know other perks
so there's a chance carly's making me
lose money again
again zach we don't have to rehash this
i did not make you lose money the first
time around
stoner cats it's donorcats.com you can
just don't think is that what it is
yeah oh yeah oh yeah it's in ashley
kutcher's uh
instagram profile too um yeah yeah
ashton and melisa
um and by the way mila is sort of pro
the
billionaire space race and watching an
interview with her about stoner cats
she was like i think people are
misunderstanding the value of
this whole space race thing and she's
like i get the criticism but i think
it's people don't really understand
she talked about space race and stoner
cats she beat us the punch here i
thought this is the only podcast
ashton was an investor in virgin
galactic and mila told him he couldn't
go to space she was like absolutely not
you're not going to space i'm going to
space
carl i'm doing it yeah no i would not be
comfortable with that i would take the
total mila
approach and was like absolutely not
back this is what's going to happen
stoner cats going to the moon and it's
going to pay for my virgin galactic
quarterback going to the moon space
tourist ride
and i'm going to be waiting there's a
pun stoner cats is going to go to the
moon
to fund your trip to the moon
i thought you were going like the cow
jumped over the moon type poem thing uh
we are now burning the end of this
podcast
carl stoner cats
and billionaire space race an episode
for what do we call this for the record
books
um great to have you thank you for
keeping me great
i'm a co-host now great to have you zach
it's great to have you
i'm glad to be in your present we're out
have a good week everybody see you next
thursday everyone
[Music]
you